we're going to take a look today at joe
biden's top moments of his presidency so
far a deep dive into the highs
uh and there is no question that we will
also be talking about the lows
welcome to the program
we have seen enough
joseph r biden jr will be the
president-elect of the united states
defeating donald trump the race has been
called by decision desk hq
others are starting to call the race
individuals familiar with particular
states are making it clear that in those
states there will be no turning back
that joe biden's leads including
newfound leads that appeared overnight
will sustain and at this point in time
we are not saying donald trump will
concede anything there is no doubt
whatsoever that donald trump is going to
be filing lawsuits and trying to get
recounts and there will be some recounts
but
because joe biden has taken leads now in
multiple states and leads have grown in
other states
joe biden is poised to be
the presumptive winner of the
presidential race and we can say that
with some comfort at this point in time
so let's take a look at some of the
numbers the latest numbers in the key
uncalled states reminder alaska is still
not called it will not matter in the end
in nevada as the vote has continued to
trickle in from 75 to 80 85 now 86
reporting at the last batch of votes
joe biden's lead growing by a few more
votes now to 21 20 and a half thousand
votes in nevada there is every
indication based on the overwhelming
amount of votes left from the las vegas
area which votes for joe biden
that the lead will grow that alone would
be enough to get joseph r biden jr to
270 electoral votes
in arizona the vote continues to come in
and there is no credible path for donald
trump to retake the lead remember that
arizona was called by both the
associated press and fox news a couple
of days ago donald trump insisting they
should keep counting the votes of course
that's what we do in elections we keep
counting the votes and they've continued
to count the votes and it does not
appear as though that will be reversed
pennsylvania overnight flipping
from donald trump to joe biden it
started two days ago as an eight point
lead for trump
they knew
the mail-in votes would be counted over
time and as that happened the lead for
joe biden shrank
i'm sorry the lead for donald trump
shrank from eight to seven six five four
three two
last night it went below one it went to
below half a point this morning it was
tied and with the latest edition of
votes joe biden has now taken a lead
of about nine 98 900 votes in
pennsylvania because of what is left to
count
experts in pennsylvania say there is no
path for donald trump to retake that
lead
in georgia
donald trump has lost his lead slowly
diminishing from a few points
to
half a point
to a tie
as of right now statistically
49.4 for each candidate
although when you go one more digit you
see that joe biden does have a slight
lead there
of about 1800 votes and so any
combination understand that nevada alone
does it for joe biden nevada experts say
nevada is done
but were he not to get nevada and even
if he were to lose arizona
pennsylvania alone would put joe biden
over 270. this makes north carolina
which has not gone either way yet
irrelevant essentially
of course if joe biden maintains georgia
he also wins
if he gets georgia but not pennsylvania
he needs certainly to maintain arizona
or nevada and of course if things end as
they are now we don't know if they will
but if they do
joe biden will end up with 306 electoral
votes more electoral votes than donald
trump had in 2016
and
a massive absolutely massive
popular vote victory as of right now the
popular vote is
in joe biden's favor by 2.7 percent
which because of the very high turnout
is nearly 4 million votes
uh just shy of that at about 2.96
million votes right now
just shy of that four m 3.96 rather just
shy of a four million vote margin it
will be a historic popular vote margin
for joseph r biden jr one last uh uh
sort of element to look at
the current count per the new york times
in pennsylvania
uh matching up with that of the
associated press a slight joe biden lead
in georgia a very slight joe biden lead
north carolina is still with no new
reporting and we are not expecting any
new reporting for some time has joe
biden down 1.4 percentage points but we
do not expect it to matter arizona the
new york times has not called but the
numbers remaining in joe biden's favor
and then again as i mentioned in nevada
with the latest update
joe biden now with a 20 or so thousand
vote lead there so ladies and gentlemen
it is happening it is happening now we
are not out of the woods in the sense of
we still don't have senate results we
still don't know what's going on with
the house in total donald trump will get
recounts in some states he's filing
lawsuits in some states he has gone
completely out of his mind and he is
unlikely to concede
insiders are saying trump will not
concede now don't worry
because concession is not a legal
process concession is a formality where
normal people when they lose say i
concede my opponent has won they call
their opponent
in ideal times you issue a message of
unity not that i liked these people but
john mccain in 2008
had to silence the boos from his
sycophants to say barack obama is a good
man we both love this country we are
with barack obama
george h.w bush when he lost in 1992 to
governor bill clinton
issuing again doesn't mean we're saying
he's a great pr was a great president he
wasn't
but he behaved like a normal person he
behaved like a normal person
even hillary clinton in 2016 despite
donald trump saying you would be in jail
if i was president
conceded despite donald trump's claims
to the contrary so we are going to be
paying very close attention over the
next few days to whether there is
violence
uh to how the vote counts continue
coming in on today's program we will be
speaking about everything from sean
hannity saying they need to redo the
pennsylvania election
trump adviser stephen bannon saying dr
anthony fauci should be beheaded yes
yes he said that uh and so much more but
the big news is
the presumptive we are not yet saying
president-elect the presumptive winner
of the 2020 presidential election is joe
biden now in advance of what i know will
be some disappointment
that biden didn't win by more
uh and that the senate and house aren't
looking great we are going to talk
about the problems on the left that led
to what should have been a blowout not
being a blowout but it's not just the
left it's also the right there is a lot
to discuss and i don't want to
shortchange that conversation so let's
not do it right now
but what i do want to remind people is
this is the removal of an incumbent
president
it is very difficult to remove an
incumbent president
bill clinton did it to george h.w bush
in 1992 that was a three-way race ross
perot was in that one there were
additional factors complexities etc
uh it is not common that you remove even
a bad incumbent president so we have to
remember when we look at the numbers
incumbent president loses by 4 million
that is a big deal it doesn't excuse the
failings of the democratic party
it does nothing it doesn't excuse the
fact that nearly 70 million trumpists
said let me vote for four more years of
that
that's horrifyingly scary but the
important thing to remember is that
removing an incumbent president is
really difficult i expect we will see
more calls by the networks over the next
few hours donald trump did speak
yesterday and we're going to have video
of that he gave a completely delusional
humiliating press briefing saying
everything is fake everything is fraud
claiming victory donald trump jr took to
twitter and said that they need to go
into total war mode which i'm worried
will lead to violence we had questions
throughout the day yesterday why does
trump want to stop counting states that
he's losing if you stop counting when
you're losing you lose we will
find out about the incompetence that was
at play there and we are even starting
to see some republicans and i'm not
saying they're good people because
they're not
but some some republicans are even
jumping ship with trump's
authoritarianism saying it's dangerous
for him to claim victory when he hasn't
it's dangerous for him to claim fraud
when he has not presented any actual
evidence of fraud and
because we want to have more good news
today if possible i will talk about the
very bad news about the pandemic
i will tell you about that 118 000 cases
yesterday but on the good news
the war on drugs was absolutely crushed
crushed on election day
very interesting numbers
uh 2016 was not a fluke
donald trump and his coalition are still
here and they are very strong they
almost got him reelected but joseph r
biden jr with multiple paths to 270 and
now we can say the presumptive winner
the race has been called by decision
desk hq and i anticipate more calls very
very soon so glad you're with me make
sure you're following me on twitter at
deepakman make sure you're following me
on instagram at david.pakman continued
coverage and much more we're now more
than a week into joe biden's presidency
there are certainly things to criticize
for example joe biden said two thousand
dollar checks are going out right away
if democrats win the two georgia seats
they haven't now it's not clear exactly
what will be in the covid relief bill
it's not exactly clear when uh that is
going to be happening so there's no
question that there are criticisms here
but if we take a sort of fair and
comprehensive
approach to the question
how does joe biden's first week compare
to donald trump's four years i would
make the case and i would feel confident
making it that joe biden has done more
good in his first eight or nine days in
office eight days in office i guess it's
been than donald trump did in his entire
four years a lot of this has to do with
the virus the coronavirus task force
being re re uh invigorated
bringing in actual qualified doctors
increasing vaccination we're already up
to 1.2 million vaccines a day
figuring out where are these
discrepancies in terms of vaccines
getting vaccines out to people number of
vaccinating locations going up
dramatically
starting to be very clear about the
possible trajectory trajectory of the
virus that alone is absolutely huge but
then you look at pausing the arms sales
to saudi arabia and the united arab
emirates
reversing a lot of the bad decisions
made by donald trump including joe biden
getting us back into paris climate
back into the who
reversing the trans-military ban working
to promote racial equality through
executive orders after donald trump did
whatever he could to get rid of any
executive orders that said hey we should
really look at this or we we should
really look at that um starting to
actually put together some potential
progress on immigration which has been
so
it's not just that the discussion's been
fraught
but it's been such a failure
under the trump administration looking
at
um
environmental regulations that are put
back in when they were once trump undid
via executive order but also canceling
keystone xl pipeline
i could go on and on and on with the
list
but the amount that he has been able to
do in these first eight or so days
really is more of a counterbalance to
donald trump's four years than i could
have ever imagined and my promise to you
when joe biden even before joe biden won
and then when he won and then when he
was confirmed by the electoral college
and when he was inaugurated
is that we are going to keep joe biden
accountable to the promises that he made
but when joe biden does things that are
good i'm going to tell you that he did
good things it doesn't mean he's perfect
it doesn't mean the democratic party is
now a bastion and beacon of
progressivism it simply means
that sometimes presidents do things that
are good and uh they should be applauded
for that and i think what has been most
fascinating to see about this
is that
the country seems to see it
uh joe biden's first approval rating 63
higher than donald trump's approval
rating at any time during his presidency
remember that donald trump never even
hit 50 percent at any time during his
presidency and presidential approval joe
biden already at 63 percent uh 69
approval of joe biden's handling of
coronavirus in these early days
80 81 approval of joe biden's federal
mass mandate and and national mask sort
of request i think is the right way to
call it so
we are in a very polarized situation
25 28 30 of the country is off the deep
end in terms of radical
ignorant politics as i call it
so when you consider that
these really are
very very good numbers for joe biden and
we are going to continue tracking uh his
promises and what he does
but the first seven eight nine days uh i
am very pleased with and i'm even
yesterday we had a voicemail from a
bernie supporter who said
i voted bernie but i i have to tell you
i'm pleasantly surprised by a lot of
what's going on and and i do believe
that
in terms of the most pressing thing
what's happening with vaccinations is
excellent and i hope that we can soon be
at two two and a half million vaccines a
day don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
within a roughly 24-hour period the joe
biden presidency took a major major hit
with joe bob joe biden not joe bommer
joe biden bombing syria
while appearing to back away from
requiring the inclusion of a 15
federal minimum wage in the covid relief
bill that's working its way through
congress now on the minimum wage the
biden administrations has come out and
said we're still committed to that we
might just do it outside of the coveted
relief bill we'll get into that in a
moment
but not a good 24 hours for joe biden
here on thursday joe biden launched
airstrikes in syria now why did joe
biden do this well he explained it or at
least tried to in a letter to
congressional leadership joe biden said
the strike was quote pursuant to the
united states inherent right of
self-defense as reflected in article 51
of the united nations charter biden
further explaining that quote at my
direction on february 25th u.s forces
conducted a targeted military strike
against infrastructure in eastern syria
used by iran-supported non-state militia
groups those non-state militia groups
were involved in recent attacks against
united states and coalition personnel in
iraq
including the february 15 attack in
irbil iraq which wounded one u.s service
member wounded four u.s contractors
including one critically and killed one
filipino contractor
however
we are right back
to the same issue of a president
obtaining authorization for use of
military force through congress this was
an issue with barack obama this was an
issue with donald trump this is now an
issue with joe biden so there are two
things here
first are the particulars of these
strikes
this is just the latest of 20 years of
american foreign policy all over again
since 9 11. they attacked us personnel
in iraq so we're retaliating okay well
so what's the point here the point is to
send the message that we won't tolerate
this all right and then what happens
next the attack sours any good will that
there was to the united states
nothing improves we rinse and repeat for
another five years of the same stuff so
i don't really care to debate whether
this particular case well there was a
service member wounded and four
contractors and a filipino killed and so
this was justified because of that
attack to be honest maybe it was under
this completely
sort of deranged
a
framework in which we've been operating
for the last 20 years maybe it was
justified in that framework maybe it
wasn't the questions are two number one
will we ever have a president who
actually dislodges the decades-long
status quo of repeating things that
don't work and just extend the status
quo
this obviously isn't going to do that
regardless of your opinion about this
particular strike and then further we
once again get to this issue of an
authorization to use military force this
all goes back to resolutions from 2001
and 2002
which were passed to give the president
the ability to go after the then
president george w bush to go after
those who did the september 11th attacks
it was used to go into war with iraq in
2003 which didn't do the september 11th
attacks but then it has been
subsequently used
to
as the legal justification for a whole
bunch of these different strikes u.s
strikes in syria u.s strikes elsewhere
and presidents always point back to the
2001 uh aumf authorization for the use
of military force as to why they can do
it but can they
many democrats say no
when it's a democrat in office many
republicans also say no although they
tend to shut their mouths when it's a
republican in the oval office doing the
same thing
so we can't be hypocrites here if the
aumf didn't cover trump stuff in syria
didn't cover obama didn't cover things
george w bush did outside of the scope
of responding to 911 it can't cover
things that joe biden does either so we
just have to pick one and i believe at
this point 20 years later the aumf is
definitely no good
so for me this is beyond any debate
about this particular incident this
particular bombing this is about more of
the same once again in these
never-ending conflicts and then
coinciding with the minimum wage
disaster joe biden included a dollar uh
a coin rather coinciding with the
serious stuff is the minimum wage
disaster joe biden included a fifteen
dollar minimum wage in his coveted
relief bill on technical grounds it's
not going to be in the senate version of
the coveted relief bill why the senate
parliamentarian elizabeth mcdonough says
a 15 minimum wage provision doesn't
comply with rules governing what can be
done via budget reconciliation so almost
certainly
even though kamala harris could overrule
that decision by the parliamentarian the
senate will likely pass a version of
covet relief not including a 15 minimum
wage it'll go back to the house the
house will have to vote on that and it
will pass without the fifteen dollar
minimum wage
i don't believe
that it's clear that a standalone bill
on a fifteen dollar minimum wage makes
it actually happen
that's increasingly what the biden
administration is pointing to saying
it's it's too big a step to override the
senate parliamentarian we are committed
to the 15 minimum wage but we will do it
separately
i don't know if that will happen
it's not clear to me that every
democratic senator wants a 15 minimum
wage so overall
not a good 48-hour period for joe biden
and we will of course be following this
this week so as we already we started
the show today talking about the
explosion of vaccination 8.8 million
vaccinations happening over this weekend
friday saturday sunday we are now uh
right around two and a half million
vaccinations per day
probably going higher this is not by
chance
this was exactly what joe biden ran on
doing
from before day one he put in place
infrastructure and a team to increase
vaccinations as quickly as possible and
it's happening now a lot of people are
insisting trump trump trump credit for
the vaccines we will talk in the next
segment about why there's really very
little trump gets credit for on the
vaccines he gets credit for not
obviously standing in the way although
downplaying the seriousness of the virus
is making it so that half of trump
voters don't want the vaccine so we'll
talk about trump's role a little bit
later
but let's talk about joe biden
on thursday night joe biden told the
nation during his first prime time white
house address as president which got
higher ratings than trump's first one
and that seems to be highly triggering
to many joe biden said he believes we
have and will have
enough supply
for every state to make all adults
meaning 18 plus eligible for vaccine
appointments as of may 1st
and many right wingers are absolutely
furious
let's take it step by step here's what
joe biden said late last week first
tonight
i'm announcing that i will direct all
states tribes and territories
to make all adults people 18 and over
eligible to be vaccinated no later than
may 1.
let me say that again
all adult americans will be eligible to
get a vaccine no later than may 1. this
is a major accomplishment say what you
want about biden on minimum wage
the stimulus taking too long not
managing the border situation well
enough i'm with you i've been on all of
those stories
but the way trump rolled out vaccination
we were thinking about
maybe 18 plus by september maybe
mid-august
may 1st eligibility for all adults is
powerful and it is huge joe biden also
saying which triggered the right very
much something optimistic
that the way things are going we are
likely to be able to have july 4th
gatherings not necessarily ragers with
500 people
but gatherings take a look at that
and finally fifth
and maybe most importantly
i promise i will do everything in my
power
i will not relent until we beat this
virus
but i need
you the american people i need you
i need every american to do their part
that's not hyperbole i need you
i need you to get vaccinated when it's
your turn and when you can find an
opportunity
and to help your family your friends
your neighbors get vaccinated as well
because here's the point
if we do all this
if we do our part
if we do this together
by july the fourth there's a good chance
you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood and have a cookout at
a barbecue and celebrate independence
day
that doesn't mean large events with lots
of people together but it does mean
small groups will be able to get
together without a doubt joe biden's
best speech and public event so far
and the right is simply furious here is
right wing bomb thrower mark levin
considered an intellectual to the modern
reactionary right-wing movement
calling this speech the most disgusting
speech
ever given
by a politician yeah this speech that
joe biden gave
is the most disgusting propagandistic
speech that a demagogue even a
politician has ever given it is pathetic
just completely irate about it here is
laura ingram
weighing in with sean hannity calling
the speech a funeral for america what do
you think of this speech
well
i think it was supposed to be inspiring
it seemed a tad like a funeral for
america however so
that's my quick take i don't even know
if she saw the speech from what she's
saying a funeral for america after trump
was vaccinating only about 850 000 a day
we did nearly 9 million in a weekend
we're opening vaccination to all adults
by may 1st biden is saying we're going
to have 4th of july gatherings it's the
opposite of a funeral they don't seem to
like the good news and then here is
laura ingram on her own excuse me on her
own show
saying there is a double standard
because the left likes joe biden saying
july 4th looks good
but they didn't like donald trump saying
easter of 2020 looks good last year
and she says there's a hypocrisy
because of this take a look well what
were the journalists saying their
reaction to this pseudo science
i think it was very moving i thought it
was really important when he talked
about that july 4th goal he is the guy
we need right now july 4th you know he
he put that on the calendar as well
right people are going to be looking at
their calendars now with some hope if we
all do our part by the fourth of july we
might be able to celebrate independence
day together which would be incredible
i don't even know who that last person
was with the mask who was that oh chris
hayes okay
now how is that based in any science now
i seem to remember a different reaction
from the press corps who were crucifying
trump for pegging reopening to a holiday
last spring
president trump pushing the country to
get up and running by easter but top
medical experts are warning it is much
much too soon we're going to have
everything lifted by easter
no the president saying i want the whole
world to be opened up by easter and
think about what bill gates just said
you do that too early and you're going
to be ignoring all the bodies in the
corner
oh my gosh i hadn't seen that until just
then
now of course the truth is the press was
acting like the comms department for the
dnc last spring laura the difference
between trump saying will be open by
easter 2020
and biden saying small fourth of july
gatherings
is that it was ridiculous to talk about
easter of 2020. there was never any
chance of that happening no medical
experts thought that was possible it was
a joke it was laughable trump was again
the humiliation globally of the united
states when we had just started taking
any measures in mid-march and trump was
saying in april we're going to be wide
open every single one of those comments
about easter of 2020 was correct
it was nutty to think of opening in
easter of 2020 and then laura ingram and
i think this is really what makes them
mad laura ingram had a panel on which
someone named molly hemingway said it's
unamerican for joe biden to say he might
allow gatherings on july 4th which is of
course not what he said take a look
again and then to pick independence day
as the day where he says he might allow
people to gather is just so un-american
and and just you know
joe biden doesn't get to tell me when i
can have a barbecue in my backyard
and certainly not to tie that to
independence day it and of course people
have been barbecuing this entire time
it's not a question of permission it's
for those who pay attention to the cdc
and what public health experts say
the way things are pointing are we could
safely do this it's not about permission
it's about working together and it
continued all night and even into the
next day from that same night sean
hannity ran a headline called biden
should thank trump for vaccine
and i tweeted about this asking can
anyone explain to me what trump actually
did on vaccination any government would
generally fund research it's not special
are we supposed to thank him trump for
not going out of his way to prevent
vaccine development trump now wants
credit
for a vaccine he said we didn't actually
need to end the pandemic to end a
pandemic that he said wasn't serious
anyway and the vaccine which he received
in private in january and kept a secret
until we learned last week that he had
been vaccinated which also doesn't
encourage people to go out and get
vaccinated they are simply furious that
this is going well
per capita on vaccination rates it's
israel
the united arab emirates the uk and
chile and then the united states we are
in the top five vaccinators in the world
per capita the next countries down have
done only like a sixth of the
vaccinations per capita that we have and
the right can't take it
part of by the way
we're going to talk later about anthony
fauci's comments about
why aren't republicans wanting to get
vaccinated part of it is
they were told this wasn't serious for a
year
part of it is they believe
that them getting vaccinated helps joe
biden be able to say look at all the
vaccinations so i expect them to keep
this going
probably straight into the 2022 election
and we'll be covering it through and
until then
next friday the 26th
we are running a massive one-day
membership promo why well the reason why
isn't the best it's that february was
our worst month in terms of memberships
in over a year
a lot of people hit with financial
trouble february only 28 days less time
for people to sign up disastrous month
for us so fr next friday the 26th we're
doing a membership blowout it'll be a
sort of vaccination related
coupon code if you want to be notified
just get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com and you'll get an email
bright and early next friday morning if
you value what we do at the david pakman
show remember to support us on patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show you are not going to
believe this or you are and maybe that's
really the problem that it's very
believable yesterday joe biden's
administration uh made a major
announcement on vaccination this is not
the surprising part i'll get you to the
surprising part in a moment uh the
administration of joe biden has been
delivering hugely when it comes to
coronavirus vaccines joe biden initially
said the goal is a hundred million doses
in a hundred days now at the time i said
we're sort of like already on track
for 89 million so it's not super
ambitious but then he doubled that goal
to 200 million doses in 100 days
joe biden then moved up the full
eligibility date to may 1st and
yesterday joe biden moved it up even
further announcing that as of now
on april 19th there will be full adult
eligibility for coronavirus vaccines in
all 50 states regardless of age
regardless of occupation
regardless of health status
and that is a really big deal we are now
giving doses to roughly one percent of
the entire u.s population every single
day about three million doses per day
huge announcement incredible success
with the accelerating vaccination
program under this administration and
when joe biden finishes
telling the united states about this
great news
peter ducey from fox news
when joe biden finishes up gets up and
yells at joe biden should the masters
golf tournament be moved out of georgia
what
yeah that's what peter ducey urgently
yelled at joe biden after a momentous
announcement with regard to vaccines and
joe biden handles it well we're going to
look at it and joe biden's approach has
been the right one to this boycott stuff
from the beginning
joe biden says companies should do what
they want to do i support businesses
deciding what's best for them
it's almost like a conservative position
but the voter suppression has to stop
check out the exchange and remember
biden's event was about vaccines
biden wasn't scheduled to take questions
biden is under no obligation to answer
stupid questions yelled at him by peter
ducey but he does anyway despite the
right narrative the right wing narrative
being that joe biden won't answer any
questions from reporters take a look at
this the masters golf tournament should
be moved out of georgia
i think that's up to
the masters look
you know
it is reassuring
to see that
for-profit operations and businesses
are speaking up about how
these new jim crow laws
are just
antithetical to who we are
there's another side to it too
the other side to it too is when they in
fact move out of georgia
the people who need the help the most
people who are making
hourly wages
sometimes get hurt the most
i think it's a very tough decision for a
corporation to make
or a group to make
but i respect them when they make that
judgment and i support whatever judgment
they make but it's the best way to deal
with this
is for georgia and other states to
smarten up
stop it
stop it
it's about giving people
you know in a sense conservatives should
love that answer these are for-profit
businesses
making
you know the the apple of the republican
eye is the for-profit business and it's
a for-profit business making the
decision they want to make
and then dealing with whatever
consequences come of it period
another thing joe biden does well there
is once he gets out of the way the
reminder that these are private
businesses deciding things for
themselves
he gets back to the core issue and i
think that this is something that we
should always be doing when this issue
comes up which is the core issue is
republicans didn't get enough votes in
2020 or what i mean by that is they
didn't suppress enough votes in 2020 in
particular this happened in georgia joe
biden took georgia first democratic
presidential candidate in a long time to
win georgia
two democratic challengers unseated two
republican incumbent senators in georgia
and so republicans are now trying to
suppress the vote even more we have more
than 250 voter suppression bills across
the country that's also happening in
georgia and joe biden puts the focus on
that that's exactly what he should be
doing one bonus clip
here joe biden after the same event is
asked if he's spoken or met with
federal reserve chairman jay powell
jerome powell he goes by jay and joe
biden says no and he explains you know
the fed is supposed to be independent
like understanding the genesis of these
organizations
biden doesn't want to get too involved
with the fed
uh and certainly isn't going to be
telling them what to do the way that
donald trump did take a listen to this
last question
have you spoken to the federal reserve
chairman jay powell yet i have not can
you say why
i am not look i think the the federal
reserve was an independent operation
and starting off my presidency i want to
be real clear
that i'm not going to do the kinds of
things that have been done in the last
administration
either talking to the attorney general
about who he's going to prosecute or not
prosecute and under what circumstances
or the fed telling them what they should
and shouldn't do even though that
wouldn't be the basis upon which i'd be
talking to him so i've been very
fastidious about not talking to them but
i do talk
to the uh the secretary of treasury
thank you all very much mr president uh
you mentioned 550. i was pleasantly
surprised
i've had my criticisms of joe biden so
far i've had my praise
biden wasn't even scheduled to take
questions he wasn't expected to take
questions he did
and he made some principles very clear
in ways that i don't think reporters
particularly liked
because it gave them nothing
and joe biden he almost seems to enjoy
toying with peter ducey who by the way i
mean if
back when you had reporters yelling
questions at trump like that
you had fox and others saying it's
disrespectful it's disrespectful to yell
out questions like that to the president
they they seem thrilled the right does
with peter ducey's questions and joe
biden handling them very well i want to
do one more peter ducey segment next
because it actually relates to a really
important discussion about georgia
colorado the all-star game and more joe
biden today is going to be making some
of the biggest foreign policy news
really in a long time as far as the
united states is concerned joe biden
will be withdrawing all u.s troops from
afghanistan
starting very soon and to be completed
by september 11th of this year the
washington post can now report
that will be 20 years to the day since
the 9 11 2001 attacks uh joe biden who
we were told by
donald trump and even by some on the
left would start wars
was some kind of bloodthirsty warmonger
would never bring troops home would send
more troops to more places
joe biden is going to do what george w
bush
barack obama and donald trump could not
do or at least did not do now i know
that some of you will be saying well
hold on a second it was going to happen
may 1st
now it's going to be september 11.
that's that's a delay what's going on uh
remember the back story of that the
trump administration negotiated a may
first deadline uh with the taliban last
year when joe biden came into office he
did something that i think is generally
smart he came in and said
he didn't say
because the trump administration was so
incompetent in every way but joe biden
came in and said i'm going to review all
ongoing projects and their associated
timelines and dates i'm pausing and
reviewing before committing to either
doing the thing donald trump started to
do or not
this included pausing and evaluating the
may 1st plan there were things about the
may 1st plan
that were real question marks including
how exactly would the withdrawal be done
who has been uh coordinated with in
terms of this withdrawal and the the
sort of cynical
interpretation from some was biden is
pausing the may first withdrawal because
he doesn't really want to leave he wants
to stay forever he may even send more
troops
in this particular case and we evaluate
other cases on their merits in this
particular case
it appears that joe biden really was
just skeptical that donald trump did
anything right and he wanted to evaluate
this plan for himself
as a result it won't be may but it's
going to be september it will take four
extra months i'd rather biden do it
competently
and have it take four more months then
simply do it the way trump planned
likely incompetently much like
everything else that donald trump did
now in terms of numbers officially there
are 2500 u.s troops left in afghanistan
the real number is more like 3 500 there
are also 7 000 foreign forces mostly
nato troops
we don't know exactly what happens with
those other troops at this point in time
but joe biden will be holding
a public event today it may have already
happened by the time you listen to
today's show or watch this clip where
maybe he will outline that
importantly joe biden's plan for
withdrawal from afghanistan
is not conditions based we are simply
getting out and a senior administration
official said to the washington post
that a conditions-based plan
would be a quote recipe for staying
forever in afghanistan that would be
very bad
the u.s is going to draw down to zero by
september 11th regardless of conditions
now we've previously
said
or asked the question
how far does american responsibility go
in places where we enter
and things break the us military goes in
things break and then we are responsible
at least to some degree you break it you
bought it as sort of the general idea
how long do you have to stay
until you can say well we now we are
getting out even if it's not totally
fixed there's very varied opinions about
this and and
much validity in different ways joe
biden has made a decision that the limit
is september 11 2021.
of course we will believe it if and when
it happens
but this has been trillions of dollars
hundreds of thousands dead millions
certainly affected by it
it is time to go
trump promised it he couldn't get it
done during his presidency biden is at
least apparently going to do it now what
will the trump supporters say
they seemed to support it when it was
donald trump who announced that this is
what he was going to be doing they
should still support it i can't imagine
they would now be rooting i don't know
for the taliban or for whoever
uh
if they supported it happening when it
was trump that announced it you would
imagine if they were consistent they
would support it now as well
some are already saying that september
11th is too soon though now how does
that make sense if may 1st was okay
how does taking four extra months
make it too soon
uh
you'd have to ask them now some
practical questions
will afghanistan destabilize after u.s
troops leave we don't know it it's
possible that that will happen
will iran get more involved maybe in
fact iran getting involved could be sort
of part of restructuring and getting
back to
the iran nuclear deal we don't know yet
that's another possibility it's
premature to assume that al qaeda simply
rises again or that the islamic state
rises again
the taliban is very opposed to the
islamic state al-qaeda has a little
presence sure al-qaeda could try to
regroup in afghanistan but there are
easier places at this point for al qaeda
to try to regroup so what we know for
now is the date is september 11 2021
let's see if the phase drawdown starts
and let's see if we are out in what is
essentially just under five months from
today but this is a good decision and it
is a major foreign policy decision
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
well everybody they uh they passed
something they they did pass something
and
we're going to talk about what that
something is after months of
negotiations as some have called them
um the house on friday passed a much
smaller
1.2 trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill
not every democrat voted for it and some
republicans voted for it those
republicans are now
being told they're going to be removed
by other republicans but we're going to
get to that um it does finally give joe
biden something that can be called a win
it's a much smaller win than i hoped for
for the good of the country it's a much
smaller win than democrats most of them
hoped for
from the standpoint of politics but it
did pass the house 228 to
206 and this is
mostly a bill
with what republicans would call
real infrastructure spending now we
don't really go by calling things what
republicans call them because if we did
we'd be very stupid um but
what what others refer to to this type
of spending as is hard infrastructure
big investments in roads bridges
waterways and other things that we're
going to talk about some that i'm
pleased to see to be perfectly frank
13 republicans voted in favor of this
bill
six democrats voted against this bill
the 13 republicans voting in favor
mostly the folks we aren't surprised to
hear would cross party lines to vote in
favor the democrats voting against um
supposed progressives as they are often
described and you know we can talk later
about whether we're surprised that they
voted against it or not nancy pelosi was
negotiating biden was helping try to get
it done
and finally on friday they got the vote
now the house goes to a recess
then they're going to take up the social
spending bill also known by some as
billed back better
many saying that's dead others saying no
sir it might pass um what some have said
they want before they will consider the
buildback better bill is a score from
the
cbo as to the total cost and economic
impact of the social spending bill slash
build back better bill so this is not
that this is the infrastructure bill now
again remember
this is
if you already were
ashamed
at the size of this package
okay
because it's 1.2 trillion instead of two
three trillion
it's number one 1.2 trillion over eight
years
uh and only 550 billion of the 1.2
trillion is new spending the rest is to
fund existing programs so
what we're talking about here
is a package
that is 69 billion dollars per year in
new spending
for an economy the size of the united
states economy
this is not a massive package at all
we're not talking about an amount of
spending that should be this difficult
to get done now what is in the bill
specifically well let's look at it um
110 billion for roads bridges
infrastructure fix ups across the
country all right 73 billion for
electric grid and power structures even
that some republicans were saying that's
not really what we should be doing in
infrastructure spending uh hint it is
um 66 billion for rail services we have
some of the most pathetic rail in the
rich developed world
65 billion for broadband we have
pathetic broadband access in the us 55
billion for water or water as some say
um that's again we
they're still part can they even drink
water in michigan out of the tap yet in
flint michigan i don't think they can 21
billion for environmental remediation 47
billion for flooding coastal and climate
resiliency very much needed as uh we
deal with sea level rise 39 billion to
modernize transit um 25 billion for
airports our airports many of them are
pathetic 17 billion for port
infrastructure remember they're mad we
don't have more room and ports to get
the chinese tchotchkes in for christmas
but they also don't want to spend on
ports well this bill would do some of
that 11 billion in transportation safety
programs 7.5 billion for electric
vehicles and charging i would honestly
like to see that much higher
i would also have loved to have seen
spending on
retrofitting for
retrofitting homes to be
completely electric but when you go
electric you can't have that inefficient
electric baseboard heating we want to go
with the super efficient heat pumps and
mini split systems and then solar you
can go house by house
listen to a very interesting podcast
about this recently you put solar panels
on the roof
you get all of the oil and uh gas heat
out you get the inefficient um uh window
acs out right i mean you go to fully
electric but
efficient electric would like to see
more on that okay 2.5 billion in zero
emission buses 2.5 billion in low
emission buses and 2.5 billion for
ferries now you might notice nothing for
sinks and showers which donald trump was
obsessed with nothing for toilets uh it
seems we're not really having to flush
toilets 10 to 15 times under joe biden
as donald trump predicted but a lot of
good things being done now if you add
that all up it's
billion
i called it roughly 550.
what's the rest you might be saying it's
a 1.2 trillion dollar package david you
only read 550 worth of spending well
it's programs already in existence
and
again
the fact that there's this much arguing
over a bill that
as it's left mostly funds existing
programs it is globally humiliating so
politically
biden needed something
this is
something it's not
great
without it it's a political disaster for
joe biden and with it there's still more
stuff to get done but it's at least
something to justify
another three months in the oval office
right it keeps you treading water you've
not drowned
but you're not safe on shore either it
keeps you treading water is sort of the
way that i would describe it so that's
what's in the bill that's what passed so
far
we now have to talk about
instantly
the civil war republicans again coming
for their own saying those 13
republicans who voted for this
uh we got to remove those